une visite présidentielle comporte son
lot de défis organisationnels
pour ses résidents du pas de calais
cette visite d' emmanuel macron et
source d'intérêt certains se sont
présentés par simple curiosité au
relativement rare que le président se
déplace quand même donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est venus d'autres avaient des
messages politiques à partager loi
sanitaire les lois liberticides
donc on est aussi très mobilisés
ce jour là le président s'arrête dans
une ville marquée par son passé minier
la semaine précédente emmanuel macron
visiter une région rurale environ 600 km
plus au sud peu importe la destination
ils sont nombreux élus ou citoyens à se
poser la question suivante
[Rires]
si emmanuel macron n'a toujours pas
confirmé qu'il se présentait à
l'élection son entourage s'activent déjà
le président a recueilli de nombreux
parrainages d'élus locaux essentiels
pour confirmer une candidature sa
formation politique a même lancé un site
de campagne attendre le plus possible
avant de se lancer dans la mêlée une
stratégie qui a été maintes fois
utilisés oui je suis candidat jacques
chirac et nicolas sarkozy ont tous deux
fait leurs annonces ou tourner à mi
février oui je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle françois
mitterrand avait même attendu jusqu'au
22 mars 1988 environ un mois avant le
premier tour de la présidentielle
etes-vous à nouveau candidat à la
présidence de la république
oui les présidents sortants croient que
leur poste leur confère une position de
force je le crois il préfère rester
celui qui gère ça avec une image de de
gestion plutôt réussi que celui qui va
dans la bataille au milieu des débats
politiques
dans des mini crise à la frontière
ukrainienne mais aussi présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne
emmanuel macron n'hésite pas à rappeler
qu'il a de grandes aussi à gérer les
attentions 17 analystes il faut aussi
défendre son bilan la fonction vient
donc avec son lot des cons veniant
une opposition une majorité il ya une
majorité est beaucoup d'opposition
surtout avec emmanuel macron qui est
centrale tout le monde se coalisent
contre nuit donc les les critiques
fusent et c'est pas forcément un
avantage les visites et les annonces
d'investissements sont elles celles d'un
chef d'état ou d'un probable candidat
certains ne s'en formalise pas accueilli
président de la république comme on doit
l'accueillir en tant que républicain
donc nous l'avons accueillie et bien
entendu c'est toujours important de
s'entendre annoncer des moyens pour
pouvoir continuer la rénovation de notre
territoire mais d'autres comme cet élu
du rassemblement national croit que
l'ambiguïté doit cesser ça pose problème
parce que du moment où on est candidat
on engage des frais évidemment hélas
aujourd'hui ces frais là de campagne
sont faits sur le avec l'argent du
contribuable parce que c'est que le
chéquier de la république comme je vous
dis donc évidemment un événement qui
clarifie sa position
ce suspense qui n'en est finalement pas
un ne pourra pas s'éterniser les
candidats à la présidence ont jusqu'au 4
mars pour confirmer leur volonté de se
présenter ici raphaël bouvier auclair
radio-canada à liévin